Hello everyone, welcome back to another episode of the Grand Prixquel podcast where we discuss
all things feeder series.
On today's episode we are going to be doing a recap of the F2 and F3 weekends at Monaco
and the Eurocup 3 weekend at Portimao.
Your hosts today are myself, Robin, Evan and Peter.
I think it's best we look over to F2 at Monaco to begin with.
In practice we had quite a few incidents in practice with both Goethe and Villagomez
hitting the wall, but I mean in Monaco this sort of thing always happens, it's almost
to be expected.
This whole weekend was just Monaco-esque, I mean even in qualifying we had John Bennett
hitting the wall as well.
The quali session was so weird, because Camara had like damage or something and then because
Bennett crashed, they pulled the red flag out and then Invicta had the time to fix Camara's
car.
How lucky.
He's so lucky, it's actually insane.
Didn't he hit the wall during his last flying lap?
Or was that Slater?
No, Freddie did, he hit it like three times, but he still came P2.
I just remember it was one of them, I don't remember which one.
Yeah, but Camara, I don't understand because it's not like he's been fast, I feel like
Tsolov, he's just been on it every single race, whereas Camara, he's been there but
not fully there, you know what I mean?
And Dunne as usual was fast, finished second in the group.
I mean Dunne, that's the thing with him, as long as he keeps it clean he can get really
good results.
He kept it clean this weekend, which is nice.
For once.
First weekend since like what?
In like six months he's kept it clean.
Was it like Qatar last time he didn't DNF?
Nah, I'm fairly sure he punted into Martins in Qatar or something happened.
That was Abu Dhabi.
Oh Abu Dhabi, yeah, but I mean the fact we have to go to last season for something is
insane.
We've had three rounds already this year and every single round something has happened.
The Group B, I mean, given who was in Group B, I think it's fairly inevitable Tsolov
will top it.
We need to have serious conversations about Kush Maini.
What is he doing?
How is he with Alpine in the first place?
The beautiful thing called money.
How much does he have, because honestly this is like, I mean he's like Dunne but if he
Was slow.
Dunne but no redeeming qualities.
Dunne but not actually Dunne, he's just bad.
Dunne off Temu.
The thing is, isn't this like Maini's like fourth year in F2 or something, third
or fourth year?
Yeah at least Verschoor, he had some form of pace, I'll give him that.
Maini somehow like he doesn't seem to improve each year, if anything he gets worse somehow
I don't know how that is possible.
Like how do you crash into someone during qualifying? Poor Van Hoepen.
The only time that line has ever been said.
Yeah I mean there's not too much to say about qualifying I reckon, so I think we're going
to the sprint which you know in Classic Monaco style is extremely uneventful.
I think I nearly fell asleep during the sprint, or at least one of the races, because actually
both of the races were pretty boring, but we'll get to the sprint first.
I nearly fell asleep during basically everything, like the only thing I didn't fall asleep through
was F1.
Yeah I still haven't, I need to watch the F1 race actually but-
Oh my god it was something, but we're not an F1 podcast, we're not talking about
that.
The thing is, historically Monaco for F2 and F3 has been semi-decent because the cars aren't-
They’re a lot smaller than F1 cars, so you have been able to overtake, but it seems like this
year they just weren't able to do anything.
Maybe F2, I think maybe they’re still traumatized from last year.
Maybe.
Dunne went to the runoff I think during the sprint to avoid another Monaco ‘25 rerun.
At least he's learning, so happy he's finally learning, but maybe if Victor Martins was there
he'd have, he's not quite found his target for this year yet, maybe that's all it is.
I heard apparently drivers are just being a lot more cautious now at Turn 1, although
that's what was happening.
So that's probably why we got nothing in the carnage this year, which is really annoying.
We didn't get any heroics into Sainte Devote, which is very sad.
Nobody's thinking they're Max Verstappen.
But yeah, pretty boring sprint.
There was a few small incidents, I think Goethe had an incident with Miyata getting a penalty
and Goethe into the pit, I think this reminds me, did you see Goethe's social media after
this?
Yeah, his story, oh my god.
I don't have a story, I wanna put this up on the thing.
It's on Twitter somewhere, I'm sure you'll find it.
I think Hayden posted it.
What do we think of that, cause personally I think, cause that is for your private story,
like close friends, you know.
Yeah, that's embarrassing to post on main in my opinion.
And on main, I mean, yes you are young, but also you are old enough to know better.
And like a level of professionalism that is still needed in the series, I mean.
Like if this was an F4 driver, I'd be like, oh my god, yeah, that's so funny, but you
are in F2.
You've been doing this for several years now, and I mean, this is something, you know, do
it on close friends, they'll have their own private Instagrams, do it on that.
Don’t show it off to everyone, cause it's just immature.
And I don't think Miyata is even doing it on purpose.
Trying to start beef with Miyata is crazy.
It would be like if Victor Martins last year on his social media was just complaining about
Alex Dunne.
I mean, he posted a story before Monaco, Victor, something about memories in Monaco or something
like that.
Memories of turn one last year, something along those lines, I don't remember what it
said exactly.
That's funny though, there's definitely between doing that and doing what Goethe did, which
is like, you know, same guy, that just comes off like being like really like, you know.
It's like when, who was it, when Aron was complaining about Antonelli in that group chat, same sort
of vibes as that.
I think that one was like the same vibe, but I don't think exactly the same style of like,
yeah, you know, like what Goethe did was like, I don't know, he was just a bit annoyed, I
suppose.
So I think moving on to the feature race, as there's literally nothing to say about the
sprint, but the feature race, we should get in a bit of another snooze first.
Until the end.
The end was entertaining.
Yeah, I mean, I mean, the moment they started pitting, I don't know, what happened to Camara?
Either it was a skill issue, or...
Was it a tire temperature thing?
I actually still don't know what happened until now.
Yeah, I mean, we don't officially know, I mean, he was saying he had no grip on the radio.
Engineer's radio was kind of crazy.
Yeah, I don't know how the engineer thought he could get away, you know, saying like his
job is essentially to advise him on like what to do.
And yet, that's the thing, like incredibly, like, how.
It's really unprofessional.
Exactly.
Even in Canada, the engineer was being a bit like, dude, are you okay?
Like, is he okay?
What just happened?
I think Canada was a bit more justified because, you know, Camara's whole wheel-to-wheel situation,
but there was kind of...
Part of your job as an engineer, to any driver in any series, is to be able to calm the driver
down and keep them kind of in check, because as a driver, it is natural for your emotions
to be all over the place, you know, all that adrenaline.
Like you see in F1, GP and Max Verstappen, you know, GP almost has to reign him in.
That is part of the job of the engineer, and there's no need to be being so rude to your
driver and being like, you know, swearing at him.
That's insane.
Don't forget that Camara is paying the team, so therefore, like, the engineer is getting
paid by, like, it's not an F1 situation where the engineers, I guess, they have a bit more,
they have more justification to be more angry at the drivers, like, act like that on the
radio, whereas you in F2, F3, the drivers are paying you, essentially.
It's just a bit of an interesting way of conduct, I suppose.
Tsolov was really impressive for being able to avoid Camara when he was going off, by
the way, like, when the replay played, that it was so close to taking them both out.
So I was really impressed by Tsolov with that.
Yeah, I mean, Tsolov for me, he's been the best driver across every single race,
this whole series.
I mean, I feel like it's just kind of, I mean, it is a weak field, I would say, especially
compared to what we had two years ago, even last year's field was quite stronger than
this, but Tsolov has been extremely impressive, and I think, you know, he's almost tidied up
His act because I think in F3 times he could be a bit, he wasn't consistent enough almost,
but now he's, but in a way that he needs to improve his consistency because he's always
win or DNF, it feels like, I mean the Canada weekend was a nightmare for him.
Yeah, I mean, he's had quite a bit of bad luck in some races,
like when he got taken out by Tasanapol in the Miami feature,
and still after that led the championship.
So yeah, I've been pretty impressed overall by Tsolov.
I mean, I really hope he can be the one to honestly win the title, but given, you know,
our good friend Mecachrome, who knows, because, I mean, Beganovic has also been up there,
and he's also been quite, I think, he's been Mecachromed in both Melbourne and Canada,
and like he's been like kind of slowly there in the background, I mean, he got a podium
again this time, and I think if he were to get some better luck, he could maybe be up there.
Of course, Dunne is another name we can't leave out. He's fast, just messy.
Yeah, but he didn't crash out anyone this weekend, which is great.
If he keeps that up, he could challenge, because I think he is incredibly fast as well.
Do you guys remember in Barcelona last year, where he went into Victor in the pits?
I remember, it was like right after Monaco.
Right after Monaco? I mean, he really had it out for Martins last year, I don't know what it was.
How was there somebody crossing the pit lane, as cars were pitting?
That was so weird. What was that about? And like, the FIA haven't said anything about it at all,
as far as I know.
Even the commentators like glazed over, like when I was watching it, I was like ‘what the hell?’
like I had to rewind to see, did I actually see that, right? I mean, firstly, it's common in
Monaco for cars to wait till the end to pit, I mean, that's a common thing, you need to be
expecting that. And like, surely you'd know, if you're the FIA, oh, these cars still need to pit,
and make sure there's nobody there. And what's that guy doing? Like, does he have a death wish?
It could have ended really bad, and I'm glad that it didn't.
I mean, there needs to be some better safety protocols in place for that not to happen again,
because-
Yeah, exactly.
It wasn't a team personnel, right?
It looked like, I think it was somebody from the FIA, I mean-
That's just even more idiotic, then. Because I thought it could have been, if it was team
personnel, that would make a bit more sense, that it's still idiotic. But if it's like the FIA,
or like, God forbid, it's like, and literally like a member of the public, that's just insane.
Yeah, it's been not too sure, it's not been officially told.
I just know it's some guy in a white shirt, but if a team personnel doesn’t have a team shirt on, then.
Yeah, that's what I thought, but I don't know, it's just a bit crazy to think about.
Well, I don't think you'd see that any other-
Could just be the nature of how Monaco is as a circuit,
and I guess they'll maybe act if they're more easy on them or something, I don't know.
So like, than is a random member of the public got in.
But, or maybe the photographers, well, I mean, I don't think they had a camera on them,
but it could have well been the photographers, I wish.
I remember a few years ago in Baku, in the F1, I think it was Gasly who
Pitted the end, and he had a ton of photographers in the pit lane,
and they were like inches away from his car, and it was like,
I mean, this has happened before, I mean, this needs to get a stricter safety protocol,
because it was fine this time, but next time, I mean, this can't keep on happening.
And looking to the overall standings now, Mini still leads, but Tsolov has closed that gap up
a lot, but we have Stenshorne and Dunne, tied on points, and Leon, fifth, which is a bit of a
surprise to me, I was not really expecting that. He's a bit of a reverse grid merchant.
Agreed. And Camara is now beaten out by him,
I mean, I mean, he lost the podium, maybe Tsolov would have beaten him if he stood on the podium,
who knows, but he lost out on a lot, and it'd be good if we could find out what actually happened
to him. By the way, Tsolov is only one away from Mini,
honestly, I think we're going to see this weekend, maybe Tsolov might overtake Mini
and get that championship lead again. As long as he didn't get any bad luck,
he should be able to. And also to note, Stenshorne and Dunne
are both on equal points. I think Stenshorne’s third, I think because of one of his race wins, but I guess
for both Rodins, it's really just as it goes. They're both pretty good,
and I think they'll both do well in the championship going into next weekend,
or this weekend, I should say. At least the top four, they're all quite
solid, honestly. Yeah, agreed.
Mini, I wouldn't have rated until like, honestly, I don't really rate Mini that well,
so I'm not as inclined to say that he's pretty decent. I mean, this weekend has shown that I
think he is. He's been consistent,
that's what he... Like even in F3, it was like, he was consistent, that's what helped him, so.
And in these championships, ultimately that's what you need to do,
because you can't be like, winning one week, then DNFing the next two.
Let's look over to Formula 3 now, and Formula 3 was quite similar to Formula 2,
and I mean, we had James Wharton with a big crash in practice. He's not been having a good time.
Yeah, that cannot be very good for him after the incident in Australia,
like immediately the next race weekend for him, again, crashes. That cannot be great.
And then with the qualifying, I mean,
I would not expect Brando Badoer to be topping a group.
I don't know anymore.
Like last year, he was, I mean, even though he was in Prema, because he was comfortably
outperformed. But he was outperformed easily by Leon and Ugochukwu.
He's topping his group by three tenths, and you know, later on, wins the feature race.
I'm going to wait a couple more weekends before I judge anything.
And yeah, Fionn McLaughlin continues, I mean, I just feel a bit bad for him,
because we know he's fast, but the season has just been struggle after struggle for him,
it's like, nothing's quite clicked yet for him, almost.
I think we're going to see a lot of this this season.
I think he'll probably come back for another season next year.
And that's when we'll go back to seeing his actual pace.
He may even be very Tsolov-esque, I mean, just Tsolov-esque that could mean doing three seasons in F3.
He's older than Tsolov was when he did F3, though, right?
I think McLaughlin's like 18.
Yeah no, he started F4 a year later than you typically do, so he's about a year older then.
Yeah.
And then yeah, Group B, Nael on top of the group and  took overall pole.
Freddie, of course, I'm trying to talk about Freddie, he was P2 in the group.
He did touch the wall twice on his final run, but managed to keep it, you know,
not damage the car too much.
I don't understand how he did that.
Because he's just, you know, he's really good, that's how.
And I mean, his first time in Monaco, and I really like how he
immediately pushed the limit in his first time here.
Rivera's been pretty impressive.
Yeah, of course, he missed out on Melbourne with injury,
and I mean, to immediately be on the pace, third in the group is really impressive.
I mean, Campos are so good as well, I mean, all their cars in the top five in qualifying.
Yeah, Meanwhile Trident, De Palo is kind of nowhere, and Stromsted is there, I guess.
I mean, Stromsted is always like on the back end of the top ten.
Yeah, at least he's in the top ten, De Palo is, I don't know what he's doing.
I mean, maybe I am biased, because I am a Freddie fan, of course, but I feel like almost this year,
based on the driver performance we've seen from all three of drivers in each team,
I feel like Campos do seem stronger.
I think it will be a tight Campos title.
You know, easily, because also, I mean, I think Campos have, if I just look at drivers overall,
I feel like Campos have a stronger lineup than Trident, because Trident are a bit too reliant
on Freddie, because, yes, De Palo did challenge for the title last year in FRECA, but other than that,
he's not done that much.
And Stromsted is sort of like, he's solid, but that's about it.
Yeah.
Yeah, like, well, at least in F3, the sprint race was quite eventful.
That car park at the hairpin was so, it started off with Taponen going into the side of Rivera,
I think, and then it just, like, everyone behind them had to, like, basically stop.
Benavides hit the wall, and then, no, he hit one of the Dams drivers, I don't remember which one.
Then he ended up in the wall, and then Christian Ho went into the back of him.
He's broken three vertebrae in his back, so I mean, we're wishing him a speedy recovery.
But I do wonder then, who's going to replace him then?
It's concerning that we've had two spine injuries in two rounds.
I mean, we had Sharp in Australia.
Yeah.
And then we have Benavides this weekend.
I feel like this has not happened that much in recent years in F2 and F3.
Yeah, so I don't know what's going on.
And normally when there are injuries, if anything it’s going to be a wrist injury,
it's going to be carrying the steering wheel, a jerk suddenly, that will cause a wrist injury,
but back injury, I mean, it is the impact.
The FIA need to look into this and see why this is happening.
Maybe we need to improve the internal crash structure of the car to kind of shield the driver more.
So Benavides is supposedly supposed to be out for about two months,
which basically puts him out of almost the entire season.
So obviously AIX are going to have a replacement for him, but I have no clue who it could be.
I'm thinking someone who came in last year, you know, someone like Bedrin.
Interestingly, the next two FRECA rounds, the next few F3 rounds, don't collide with FREC.
We could see a FREC driver, but we also could see someone, like, unemployed.
Yeah, because I remember last year, Freddie, raced one race for AIX,
so we could see somebody like, you know, KNB maybe doing one round of- Complete speculation.
Yeah, we don't actually know anything.
The Grand Prixquel podcast is not a news source.
Yeah, we are recording on the Tuesday after Monaco, so...
If they announce it right after we're recording, again, I think I'm going to cry.
British F4, I'm looking at you.
But yeah, so obviously we hope that Brad gets better, cause that's a really serious injury.
And then yeah, Freddie also is a bit of a terrorist that race.
He went into, who was it, like, Rivera and Nael?
What happened is, it was down the hairpin,
Freddie tried to go down the inside of Rivera, but it ended up making contact,
and Nael was just unlucky to be the guy behind Freddie,
not having enough time to react, and went into the back of him.
Poor Rivera. Rivera got terrorized twice in one race.
It's like, why did I come back to this?
And then on the road, Yamakoshi won, but then he had push rods on the wrong side, he got disqualified.
The stewards document was hilarious.
The team were basically trying to argue that the push rods being labeled LH and RH
was unclear, that that meant right hand and left hand.
I feel like even a five year old could figure L.
What does it stand for? Like Lewis Hamilton and Rewis Hamilton?
Yeah, putting Lewis Hamilton onto the car.
I mean that is how you're going to win, it's just Lewis Hamilton in there, he is one of the GOATs.
But yeah, I don't know, the stewards document when I read it,
cause I really do like looking into the stewards documents and seeing what's going on.
Like some of them can be really funny sometimes.
I mean, at least the sprint race was quite eventful.
I mean, not that there was much racing, but we had incidents.
The feature race, however.
Feature race was nothing.
I mean, props to Badoer, he had a great start and that's what won him the race.
I was paying attention here, the top 10 didn't change since the first lap, I swear.
Yeah, sounds about right.
That's the problem with no pit stops in F3.
It could have been really interesting if they did.
And I think maybe after this chaotic sprint race they were maybe being a bit more conservative
and not going for moves.
Yeah, so really the only thing that happened was Taponen was put into the wall by Gladysz.
That's it.
I'm sorry, guys, there's literally no even like,
at least F2 towards the end something happened.
F3 was genuinely putting me to sleep.
The snooze fest, of all snooze fests.
Yeah, but look towards championship.
And still, you know,Ugochukwu, Del Pino, Slater, Badoer, Nile, which almost makes sense.
I mean, Freddy, I mean, he was tied on points with Del Pino before, but then,
I mean, Del Pinois low-key being a sprint merchant.
Yeah, VAR in general have been sprint merchants, but I'll take it if it benefits Enzo.
Well, it's not like he did much this weekend.
Yeah, Enzo was kind of nowhere.
Oh yeah, we forgot to mention the ridiculous amount of penalties after the sprint.
Like half the grid got drive-throughs turned into 30 seconds.
Because what was it like the mechanics touched to the car during the red flag,
or like when they were restarting after the red flag?
Something along those lines.
And like half the grid got drive-throughs turned into 30 seconds for that.
And Enzo also got another 10 seconds on top of that for cutting the corner in turn one
and gaining an advantage.
Yeah, I think this championship is going to involve into Ugochukwu-Slater title fight,
because I mean, Del Pino, I mean, it’s literally sprint race this series, he won the first sprint race in the second this weekend.
And that's getting him a majority of his points.
So that can't last forever.
I'd like to see Nael in the title fight as well, though.
Yeah, I mean, I think he does have the pace, but then maybe, how do Campos play that then?
No idea.
Because also they need to make sure there's no
contact or anything because, you know, Team Championship is on the line as well.
Yeah, I guess we'll see in future rounds what Campos decide to do.
It could be like last year, you know, how Boya ended up like,
what was it, third in the championship by the end?
Yeah.
It could end up like that.
Now moving on to EC3.
Why is Tommy Harfield here?
I need to take a deep breath before we start Eurocup-3.
Because this weekend, this weekend has been a weekend of all time.
Oh my god.
Okay, first of all, Tommy Harfield.
It was nice to see him on the pace.
I was looking through testing during the week because they had testing on Tuesday and Wednesday.
And he was consistently up there in the top 15-ish.
And I was pretty impressed considering, you know, it's his first regional race.
It didn't really translate as well to qualifying and the races,
but I was still pretty impressed by his debut.
So quali one.
We had Feghali on pole and we had three Campos' of Powell,
Strauven and Heuezenroeder in the top 10.
Campos has really locked in finally because, I mean, up until this weekend,
their other drivers other than Powell were kind of nowhere.
So it's nice to see Campos, you know, finally lock in on qualifying.
What is up with Eyckmans, though?
Eyckmans was, I don't know what happened to him.
When I said nowhere on the docs, he was kind of like in the lower top 10.
So he was still there, but not there.
You'd expect him to be top 5.
Yeah, I feel like from our top 4, like we had before the season,
only three of them will perform.
Maybe once someone won, the fourth one won't be there for some reason,
and like going into the season.
It's five drivers.
Have you forgotten Al-Azhari again?
Yes.
Out of the five drivers that, you know, we kind of expected to do well
of Egozi and Al-Azhari, Powell, Eyckmans and Lammers,
it's always one or two of them not there every weekend.
It's like, apart from Egozi, he's always there.
Yeah, Egozi, this is the easiest Egozi championship ever.
If he loses this, imagine the fumble.
Yeah, I mean, I'll get into this in a bit, but the championship lead is insane.
I mean, it’s the Alex Palou Witchcraft.
Exactly.
He's hired the same Etsy witch that Alex Palou has.
I mean, Alex Palou, he races for Palou Motorsport.
Alex just got it for him.
It comes from being part of the team.
Are you actually- I'm actually kind of shocked with this ridiculous Alex Palou luck.
Like he finally had a bit of bad luck the last weekend in Indycar,
but otherwise he's been insanely lucky this season.
Yeah, race one.
It's okay, Rob.
Okay, deep breath.
The race one was horrible for me as a fan, but the racing this weekend was pretty good.
EC3’s always delivered with the races, I mean.
Yeah, the races are great, more interesting than F2 and F3.
However, as a fan, and obviously I really, really like Alex Powell.
So in a four-way fight for the lead, there was a four-way fight for the lead
on the first lap, which was kind of crazy.
F2 and F3 could never.
Four-way fight between, who was it?
I think it was Lammers, Powell, Egozi, and Feghali.
Yeah.
But in that four-way fight for the lead,
Feghali tapped the back of Alex's car, sent him spinning into the barrier,
and Alex managed to continue on, but he came into the pits later and had to retire the car.
I mean, that's, that'd been, I think, he could have won that race, directly in the fight for it.
He could have won, he could have podiumed, he could have gotten a P4.
Anything is better than a DNF.
I reckon he had a solid podium locked in there, possible win.
Exactly.
Based off the pace he's shown over the weekend.
What I'm more upset about is that Feghali got five seconds.
Not even 10 seconds, five.
He fully takes out another driver, it's only five seconds.
The stewards document says that because Alex slowed down a little bit to avoid a collision
with the two guys that were in front, because Alex slowed down,
it caused Feghali to go into the back of him, so there were quote-unquote mitigating factors.
I don't believe that, that is woke nonsense.
Feghali’s paid the stewards off.
This is a joke, by the way, please don't cancel me, guys.
Moving on to later on in the race, because clearly I have not had enough of a bad time.
Strauven and Heuzenroeder were fighting for position,
and Heusenroeder literally just takes Strauven out and gets a 10-second penalty for it.
See how people can get 10-second penalties, Eurocup-3 stewards.
Notice how that's a thing.
And then we had Tommy Harfield into the gravel.
Yeah, and Heuzenroeder also got another post-race penalty
for leaving the track and gaining an advantage,
so he ended up with 20 seconds worth of penalties by the end of the race.
What is it with everyone being penalized in everything this weekend in all the series?
I don't know.
Even like in a Spanish F4 had a ton of penalties.
Is this the weekend of penalties?
I don't know.
No one can behave themselves.
But Al-Azhari stalled the start again, he did this in the first weekend as well,
I don't know why he keeps doing this, but he stalled again.
Someone needs to teach him how to actually start the car.
But he recovered pretty well, I think.
I don't remember where he placed, but-
He did this last time, but they keep on stalling.
There’s only so far you can go is if they're starting at the top five,
it's not like you can make it back to maybe the podium.
They're going to maybe make it into the top ten, but not top five, I reckon.
So yeah, the podium ended up being Egozi, Lammers, and Dall’Agnol.
It was originally Egozi, Lammers, and Feghali, but then Feghali got a penalty,
so then it was Egozi, Lammers, and Heuzenroeder, but then Heuzenroeder also got penalties,
so then it ended up being Egozi, Lammers, and Dall’Agnol.
And yeah, Egozi, after race one, already had a pretty big championship lead
because three out of his four title contenders had really bad races.
Eyckmans had some sort of- I don't know what happened to him,
but I think some sort of engine problem, something, I don't know.
But he also DNF'd alongside Powell, and Al-Azhari stalled the start.
So the only person who did well other than Egozi was Lammers, who got on the podium.
So yeah, even after race one, it's pretty clear to see that Egozi’s kind of the championship
favorite.
I mean, he has like, what, a 50-point lead or something insane?
We'll get into that later, because it's crazy.
Quali two, this time instead of Eyckmans, Lammers was nowhere,
and by nowhere I actually mean nowhere.
He qualified like P19, and I don't know what happened to him.
Egozi was on pole, as usual.
Um, good from Campos again, Powell was P5 this time.
He was P4 for the first race.
He overtook both Palou cars, or two of the three Palou cars ahead of him,
of Perard and Dall’Agnol, and ended up P3.
Then, eventually, as the race went on, and people were fighting for positions,
Perard crashed into the side of Alex.
And put him in the wall, or the barrier.
And I am, I can't do this, I can't do this anymore.
What curse does Alex Powell have on him?
Because even in the winter series, I remember,
like in the Formula Regional Middle East, in EC3 winter,
there's always some subplot going on with him, which is not even his fault.
Sanson went on like a whole monologue about like, Alex's luck,
and like, what does he have to do to get better luck,
and how like, this stuff can't be happening to a nicer guy.
And it made me really upset, and I was like,
I was thinking like, Sanson, please stop, I'm going to start crying.
I actually feel really bad for him, and think the pace has been there for him every round.
I've kind of talked about this a bit before,
but this season is so much better than last year in terms of pace.
We are, we are fast.
We are, we are up there, we can get podiums.
We can get wins, but the luck is non-existent.
Like, I've talked about his luck in F4 Middle East last year,
but this is so much worse.
But yeah, um, Perard got, Perard DNF'd after that,
and got a five place grid drop for the next race,
which is so much better than the five seconds that Feghali got.
I am, I can't do this.
I am on a Palou Motorsport hate watch,
but the thing is, I really like Alex Palou himself, so.
My thought on Alex Palou is, okay, he's a nice guy.
I can't hate watching him because he seems so nice.
I'm like, how is he so happy every time after he wins?
I don't understand.
Yeah, he treats every race win like it's his first,
and I think that's so nice.
It's so sweet.
And I'm like, I can't hate him, but also I want to.
Sorry Alex, if you're listening to this.
Why would Alex Palou listen to our podcast?
We talk about his drivers!
But yeah, so Egozi won the race, Fork found in kitchen.
Lammers really had no pace at all the entire race,
but because of all the collisions and penalties
and all the stuff that happened ahead of him,
I think he ended up P9 by the end.
Poliam ended up being Egozi, Dall’Agnol, and Al-Azhari.
Feghali DNF'd which karma, but there's nothing else I can say.
He just kind of stopped.
I don't actually know what happened to him.
Sanson said it was a puncture,
but after the replay I don't think it was a puncture,
so I don't know what happened to him.
Strauven and Heuzenroeder finished the race with no penalties,
and I think after the penalties for other drivers,
they finished 5th and 6th,
which is really good considering both of them
have kind of been nowhere since the winter series.
I'm sad for Feldmann Neto because he was in the points,
I think he finished P8,
but then got penalized afterwards for overtaking under safety car.
He cannot win.
During Formula Regional Middle East, he was constantly in incidents.
Then as soon as he's about to score points,
whether it's here or whether it's in EuroFormula Open,
something always happens to him.
And then Pradel ended up getting a 2-place drop for Race 2 somehow.
I don't know how that works,
but he dropped 2 places in the final classification for Race 2 for causing a collision.
So overall, I need whatever Etsy witch Egozi has.
A 100% podium race is actually insane.
5 races, 5 races, 3 wins, a P2 and a P3.
I mean, what is this luck?
Before I get into the drivers' standings,
I wanted to mention something that Sanson pointed out,
which was that obviously we went into the season thinking
it would be Campos and MP dominance,
but it's kind of not been.
We've gotten a lot of Palou dominance.
Hitech is up there.
Campos and MP have kind of been nowhere.
Sanson said this, so it's not me being biased by the way,
but Sanson was saying that out of all the Campos and MP drivers,
the only driver who we've been consistently seeing pace from is Powell.
The others have been nowhere, or not nowhere.
Eyckmans and Lammers have been up there,
but in general, Powell is the best out of all of them,
and because of his own bad luck, we haven't really seen a lot.
Again, not my words, Sanson's.
I really like Jake Sanson.
He's one of the top Alex Powell glazers out there,
and I really appreciate that.
I wonder why you like him, then.
Totally not related to him liking Alex Powell, is it?
Definitely not.
But yeah, so Championship standings.
Egozi leads, obviously, on 106 points.
P2?
How many points does P2 have?
62.
He's actually insane.
What?
It's just, I mean, Al-Azhari hasn't helped himself with stalling twice.
Yeah.
So Al-Azhari is in P2 on 62 points.
Interestingly, something I noticed is,
Egozi and Al-Azhari are the only two to have scored in every race.
Oh, yeah, that makes sense considering their winter series performance.
But Egozi has 100% podium rate.
So P3 is Lammers on 50 points,
P4, Eyckmans on 46,
and P5, Dall’Agnol on 42.
That's the top five.
Other drivers that I wanted to mention, aka the Campos drivers,
Powell is P6 on 27 points.
A lot of the points that he lost were obviously not his fault with the two DNFs this weekend.
He really should have more than 27 points.
But whatever, what can we do about it?
He probably lost at least 30 points this weekend, I feel like.
Yeah.
Um, so Strauven is P11 on 13 points,
Tarnvanichkul is P12 on 12 points,
and Heuzenroeder is P15 on 9 points.
So not a great time for the Campos drivers.
I don't actually remember what the Teams Championship looks like.
Give me two seconds.
Teams Championship.
Palou Motorsport leads on 150 points,
MP Motorsport is on 106,
and Hitech is on 77.
Campos is on 58 in P4.
It has not been a great time.
We're the last out of the actually competent teams.
They were saying that MP Motorsport has the same number of points as Egozi.
My god.
He would be leading the Teams Championship by himself.
It's insane.
So overall, what we've learned is that Eurocup-3 is not a real championship,
and it cannot hurt me.
What's not real cannot hurt me.
We also had a few other F4 series racing this weekend,
which we can give in a brief mention.
So in Spanish F4, we still have Rocco Coronel leading the Championship.
However, his margin has been cut down a lot.
But it's quite an interesting weekend,
because I feel like whoever won was not.
I mean, they had Kasper Schormans and Borys Lyzen winning races.
But I mean, you'd kind of like in the winter series.
It is very much Vivek Kanthan,
and Nathan Tye seemed like would be main challengers.
And Noah Monteiro as well.
And Monteiro.
But they, along with Coronel, weren't really anywhere this weekend.
I mean, Coronel still got a podium.
He inherited it after penalties.
I think he finished that race originally in P5.
The races were really interesting,
and I'd recommend if you got bored of F2 and F3,
I do recommend going back and rewatching the Spanish F4 races,
because there was a lot going on.
We had multiple last lap shootouts,
and a last lap shootout in an F4 series is never a good idea.
Other than Spanish F4.
We also had CEZ F4 on this weekend.
The main thing I wanted to talk about was Matilda Paatz.
She was in P2 in race 1, but got spun out by another driver.
Ended up in last place, continued the race, recovered up to P14.
Which, I was really impressed by that.
Obviously, I got really sad that she missed out on a podium.
And these CEZ F4 races, there's no reverse grids.
It's on merit.
She qualified, I think she qualified P4.
Went up to P2, got crashed out,
went back to last place, and then recovered to P14.
And then finished race 2 in P4.
She was fighting for a podium at some point.
Finished the race P5 on the road,
but then someone ahead of her got penalized, so she ended up P4.
And I've been really impressed by her here and in F1 Academy.
So, yeah, and I think looking towards the championship,
Walther has taken the lead back from Elia Weiss,
but I mean, they're quite- they’re only about 10 points apart
from each other in the standings, so it's not too far apart.
The thing is about the CEZ standings, is that the results of race 4 are provisional,
because there are 11 drivers who are currently under investigation
for some sort of technical infringement,
where the steward's document says that whoever is investigating them,
is unsure whether the cars conform to the regulations or not.
What do you mean you're unsure? Either they conform or they don't.
They're just making it up as they go.
Yeah, so there's 11 drivers who we don't know if their cars conform or not.
So we'll obviously have to wait and see what comes from that investigation,
because again, it is only Tuesday.
The race weekend ended two days ago, so we still don't know anything yet.
The results are still provisional as of now.
We'll have to wait and see, I guess.
Central European Zone F4 is not a real series.
What is happening?
And I think that's it for today's episode.
Thank you guys for listening.
If you have any comments or anything else you'd like to let us know,
make sure to follow us and let us know on all our socials,
Twitter, Instagram, and TikTok at grandprixquel.
Our next episode will be a recap of the upcoming F2 and F3 weekends at Barcelona,
so make sure to tune in for those.
Thank you for listening.